Il y a quatre ans,
un chercheur en sécurité,
ou, comme la plupart des gens l'appelleraient, un hacker,
a trouvé un moyen pour que les distributeurs de billets
lui envoient littéralement de l'argent dessus.
Son nom était Barnaby Jack,
et cette technique fut, plus tard, appelée « Jackpotting »
en son honneur.
Je suis ici aujourd'hui parce que je pense
qu'on a vraiment besoin des hackers.
Barnaby Jack
aurait facilement pu devenir
un criminel de carrière ou un méchant de James Bond
avec ses connaissances.
Mais il a choisi à la place de montrer au monde
le fruit de ses recherches.
Il pensait que parfois,
on a besoin de prouver l'existence d'une menace
pour initier une solution.
Et je ressens la même chose.
C'est la raison pour laquelle je suis ici aujourd'hui.
Nous sommes souvent terrifiés et fascinés
par le pouvoir qu'ont désormais les hackers.
Ils nous font peur.
Mais les choix qu'ils font
ont des conséquences importantes
qui influent sur nous tous.
Donc je suis ici aujourd'hui parce que je pense que l'on a besoin des hackers,
et, en fait, il se pourrait
qu'ils soient le système immunitaire pour l'âge de l'information.
Ils nous rendent parfois malades,
mais ils trouvent aussi ces menaces cachées
dans notre monde,
et ils nous forcent à les réparer.
Je sais que je pourrais me faire hacker
pour avoir fait ce discours,
alors laissez-moi vous épargner le travail.
Dans le vrai style de TED,
voici ma photo la plus honteuse.
Mais ça serait difficile pour vous de m'y trouver,
parce que je suis celle qui ressemble à un garçon
debout sur le côté.
J'étais une telle geekette à l'époque
que même les garçons de l'équipe de Donjons & Dragons
ne voulaient pas que je les rejoigne.
Ça, c'est qui j'étais.
Mais ça, c'est qui je voulais être :
Angelina Jolie.
Elle jouait le rôle d'Acid Burn
dans le film de 1995 « Hackers ».
Elle était belle et elle savait faire du roller,
mais d'être un hacker, c'est ça qui lui donnait du pouvoir.
Et je voulais être tout comme elle,
alors je me suis mise à passer beaucoup de temps
sur des sites de discussion et des forums de hackers.
Je me souviens qu'un soir, tard,
j'ai trouvé un bout de code PHP.
Je ne savais pas vraiment à quoi il servait,
mais je l'ai copié-collé
et je l'ai quand même utilisé
pour entrer dans un site protégé par mot de passe,
comme ça.
Sésame, ouvre-toi !
C'était une astuce simple,
et j'étais juste une débutante à l'époque.
Mais pour moi, cette astuce,
je me sentais comme ça,
comme si j'avais découvert un potentiel illimité
au bout de mes doigts.
Ça, c'est l'afflux de puissance que ressentent les hackers.
Ce sont des geeks exactement comme moi
qui découvrent qu'ils ont accès à un super-pouvoir,
qui nécessite le talent et la ténacité
de leur intellect,
mais heureusement, pas d'araignées radioactives.
Mais un grand pouvoir
implique de grandes responsabilités,
et tout le monde aime à penser que si l'on avait de tels pouvoirs,
on ne les utiliserait que pour faire le bien.
Mais si vous pouviez lire les e-mails de votre ex,
ou ajouter un ou deux zéros à votre compte en banque,
que feriez-vous ?
En effet, de nombreux hackers n'ont pas su résister
à la tentation,
et ils sont ainsi responsables, d'une manière ou d'une autre,
de milliards de dollars de pertes par an,
par la fraude, les malwares, ou tout simplement les vols d'identité
qui sont un problème grave.
Mais il y a d'autres hackers,
des hackers qui aiment juste casser des codes,
et ce sont justement ces hackers
qui peuvent trouver les points faibles dans notre monde
et nous permettre de les réparer.
Voici ce qui s'est produit l'an dernier,
quand un autre chercheur en sécurité,
appelé Kyle Lovett,
a découvert une faille béante
dans la conception de certains routeurs wifi,
comme ceux que vous pouvez avoir chez vous ou à votre bureau.
Il s'est rendu compte que n'importe qui pouvait se connecter à distance
à ces appareils via internet
et télécharger des documents depuis les disques durs
attachés à ces routeurs,
sans avoir besoin de mot de passe.
Il en avertit l'entreprise, bien sûr,
mais ils ignorèrent son rapport.
Peut-être qu'ils pensaient qu'un accès universel
était une fonctionnalité normale, et non un bug...
jusqu'à il y a deux mois,
quand un groupe de hackers l'utilisèrent
pour accéder aux fichiers des gens.
Mais ils n'ont rien volé.
Ils ont laissé un message :
« N'importe qui dans le monde peut accéder
à votre routeur et à vos documents.
Voici ce que vous devriez faire pour empêcher ça.
Nous espérons que ça vous a aidé. »
En accédant ainsi aux fichiers des gens,
oui, ils ont enfreint la loi,
mais ils ont aussi forcé cette entreprise
à réparer leur produit.
Faire en sorte que les vulnérabilités soient connues du public
est une pratique appelée la divulgation publique
dans la communauté des hackers,
et c'est controversé,
mais ça me fait réfléchir à la façon dont les hackers
ont un effet évolutif sur les technologies que nous utilisons
tous les jours.
Voici ce qu'a fait Khalil.
Khalil est un hacker palestinien de Cisjordanie,
et il a trouvé une faille de confidentialité inquiétante sur Facebook
qu'il a tenté de signaler
dans le programme de prime au bug de l'entreprise.
Ce sont des arrangements généralement très avantageux pour les entreprises :
récompenser les hackers qui révèlent les vulnérabilités
qu'ils trouvent dans leurs codes.
Malheureusement, en raison d'un malentendu,
son rapport n'a pas été accepté.
Frustré par cette discussion,
il a décidé d'utiliser sa propre découverte
pour poster sur le mur de Mark Zuckerberg.
Pour ce qui est d'attirer leur attention, ça a bien marché,
et ils ont réparé le bug.
Mais comme il ne l'avait pas signalé correctement,
on lui a refusé la prime généralement payée
pour ce genre de découverte.
Heureusement pour Khalil,
un groupe de hackers veillait sur lui.
En fait, ils ont levé plus de 13 000 dollars
pour le récompenser de cette découverte,
générant un débat vital dans l'industrie de la technologie
sur comment on peut inciter
les hackers à agir comme il faut.
Mais je pense qu'il y a une histoire encore plus importante derrière cela.
Même les entreprises créées par des hackers,
comme Facebook,
ont encore une relation compliquée
avec les hackers.
Alors pour des organisations plus traditionnelles,
cela va prendre du temps et des efforts d'adaptation
pour accepter la culture des hackers
et le chaos créatif qui vient avec.
Mais je pense que ça en vaut la peine,
parce que l'alternative,
combattre aveuglément tous les hackers,
c'est aller à l'encontre d'un pouvoir que l'on ne peut pas contrôler
au prix de la répression de l'innovation
et de la régulation du savoir.
Ce sont des choses qui vous retombent sur le nez.
C'est encore plus vrai
si l'on s'en prend aux hackers
qui sont prêts à risquer leur propre liberté
pour des idéaux comme la liberté du web.
En particulier en des temps comme le nôtre,
alors que les gouvernements et les entreprises
se battent pour contrôler internet.
Je trouve ahurissant
que quelqu'un des recoins sombres du cyberespace
puisse devenir sa voix d'opposition,
et même sa dernière ligne de défense,
peut-être que quelqu'un comme Anonymous,
le porte-drapeau de l'hacktivisme mondial.
Aujourd'hui, on ne présente plus
ce mouvement de hackers du monde entier,
mais il y a six ans,
ils n'étaient pas beaucoup plus qu'une sous-culture d'internet
dédiée au partage d'images stupides de chats marrants
et aux campagnes de trolling d'internet.
Le moment de leur transformation date du début 2008,
quand l’Église de Scientologie
a tenté de supprimer certaines vidéos ayant fuité
sur certains sites web.
C'est là que les Anonymous ont été façonnés
à partir de ce rassemblement apparemment confus
de gens qui traînaient sur internet.
Et il s'avère
qu'internet n'aime pas
que l'on essaie de lui enlever des choses !
Et il réagit, avec des cyber-attaques
et des blagues sophistiquées
et avec une série de manifestations
organisées tout autour du monde,
depuis ma ville de Tel-Aviv
à Adélaïde en Australie.
Ceci a prouvé qu'Anonymous, et cette idée,
peut déplacer les foules de leurs claviers
jusqu'à la rue,
et cela a posé les fondations
pour les dizaines d'opérations suivantes
contre ce qui a été perçu comme des injustices
contre leur monde en ligne et hors-ligne.
Depuis, ils se sont attaqués à de nombreuses cibles.
Ils ont dévoilé de la corruption, de la maltraitance,
ils ont hacké des papes et des politiciens.
Et je pense que leur effet va plus loin
que de simples attaques de déni de service
qui font planter des sites web
ou même de faire fuiter des documents sensibles.
Je pense que, comme Robin des Bois,
ils sont dans le marché de la redistribution.
Mais ce qu'ils recherchent, ce n'est pas votre argent,
ce ne sont pas vos documents. C'est votre attention.
Ils braquent les projecteurs sur les causes qu'ils soutiennent
nous obligeant à les remarquer,
agissant comme une loupe à l'échelle mondiale
pour des problèmes dont nous ne sommes pas au courant,
alors que nous devrions peut-être l'être.
Ils ont été traités de beaucoup de noms
de criminels à terroristes,
et je ne peux pas justifier leurs procédés illégaux,
mais les idées pour lesquelles ils se battent,
sont importantes pour nous tous.
En réalité,
les hackers font bien plus que de casser des choses.
Ils peuvent rassembler les gens.
Et si internet n'aime pas
qu'on essaie de lui enlever des choses,
regardez donc ce qu'il se passe
quand on essaie de couper internet.
Ça s'est produit en Égypte en janvier 2011,
et quand le président Hosni Moubarak
a tenté une action désespérée
pour écraser la révolution qui montait dans les rues du Caire,
il a envoyé ses troupes personnelles
chez les fournisseurs d'accès Internet d’Égypte
et les a fait physiquement couper
la connexion entre le pays et le reste du monde en une nuit.
Qu'un gouvernement fasse une telle chose
était inédit,
et pour les hackers, c'est devenu une affaire personnelle.
Des hackers comme le groupe Telecomix
étaient déjà actifs sur le terrain,
aidant les Égyptiens à contourner la censure
avec des astuces ingénieuses comme le code Morse
et la radio amateur.
C'était la pleine saison du low-tech
que le gouvernement ne pouvait pas bloquer,
mais quand le Net s'est complètement arrêté,
Telecomix a sorti l'artillerie lourde.
Ils ont trouvé des fournisseurs d'accès européens,
qui avaient encore une infrastructure d'accès par appel analogique
vieille de vingt ans.
Ils ont ouvert 300 de ces lignes
pour que les Égyptiens les utilisent,
fournissant une connexion internet lente mais appréciable
aux Égyptiens.
Ça a marché.
Ça a en fait si bien marché
qu'un type l'a même utilisé pour télécharger un épisode
de « How I met your mother ».
Mais alors que l'avenir de l’Égypte est toujours incertain,
lorsque la même chose s'est produite en Syrie
un an plus tard seulement,
Telecomix était prêt avec ces lignes internet,
et Anonymous,
ils étaient peut-être le premier groupe international
à dénoncer officiellement les actions
de l'armée syrienne,
en défigurant leur site web.
Mais avec ce genre de pouvoir,
ça dépend vraiment de là d'où vous regardez,
parce que celui qui est un héros pour quelqu'un
peut être vu comme le méchant par quelqu'un d'autre.
Et ainsi, l'Armée Électronique Syrienne
est un groupe de hackers pro-Assad
qui soutient son régime contesté.
Ils ont piraté de multiples cibles de haut niveau
ces dernières années,
y compris le compte Twitter d'Associated Press,
avec lequel ils ont posté un message
sur une attaque de la Maison Blanche
qui aurait blessé le président Obama.
Ce tweet était faux, bien sûr,
mais la chute de l'indice du Dow Jones qui en a résulté ce jour-là
ne l'était pas du tout,
et beaucoup de gens ont perdu beaucoup d'argent.
Ce genre de choses se produit dans le monde entier maintenant.
Dans les conflits de la Péninsule de Crimée
à l'Amérique Latine,
de l'Europe aux États-Unis,
les hackers sont une force d'influence
sociale, politique et militaire.
Individuellement ou en groupes,
des bénévoles dans les conflits militaires,
il y a des hackers partout.
Ils sont issus de toutes sortes de modes de vie,
de groupes ethniques, d'idéologies et je me dois de l'ajouter, de sexes.
Ils sont en train de façonner le théâtre mondial.
Les hackers représentent une force exceptionnelle pour le changement
au XXIe siècle.
C'est parce que l'accès à l'information
est une monnaie d'échange de pouvoir cruciale,
que les gouvernements aimeraient bien contrôler,
ce qu'ils essaient de faire en installant
des programmes de surveillance à volonté,
chose pour laquelle ils ont besoin de hackers, soit dit en passant.
Et donc le pouvoir établi a depuis longtemps
une relation d'amour et de haine avec les hackers,
parce que les mêmes personnes qui diabolisent le piratage
l'utilisent aussi à fond.
Il y a deux ans,
j'ai vu le général Keith Alexander.
C'est le directeur de la NSA et le cyber-commandant des États-Unis.
Mais au lieu de son uniforme de général à quatre étoiles,
il portait un jean et un T-shirt.
C'était à DEF CON,
la plus grande conférence de hackers du monde.
Peut-être que, comme moi, le général Alexander
ne voyait pas 12 000 criminels ce jour-là à Las Vegas.
Je pense qu'il a vu du potentiel inexploité.
En fait, il était là pour donner un discours de recruteur.
« Ici, dans cette pièce, a-t-il dit,
se trouve le talent dont a besoin notre nation. »
« Eh bien, ont répondu des hackers au dernier rang,
alors cessez de nous arrêter. »
(Applaudissements)
En effet, pendant des années,
les hackers ont été du mauvais côté de la barrière,
mais à la lumière de ce que l'on sait maintenant,
qui est plus attentif à notre monde en ligne ?
Les règles du jeu ne sont plus si claires,
mais les hackers sont peut-être les seuls
à être encore capables de défier les gouvernements abusifs
et les entreprises accumulatrices de données
sur leur propre terrain.
Pour moi, cela représente l'espoir.
Pendant ces trois dernières décennies,
les hackers ont fait beaucoup de choses,
mais ils ont aussi eu un impact sur les libertés civiles,
l'innovation et la liberté d'internet,
alors je pense qu'il est temps de regarder à deux fois
la façon dont on les décrit,
parce que si on continue à attendre d'eux qu'ils soient les méchants,
comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent être aussi les héros ?
Mes années dans le monde des hackers
m'ont fait me rendre compte
à la fois du problème et de la beauté des hackers :
ils ne peuvent tout simplement pas voir quelque chose de cassé dans le monde
et le laisser ainsi.
Ils se sentent forcés
soit de l'exploiter, soit d'essayer de le changer,
et ainsi ils trouvent les aspects vulnérables
de notre monde qui change si vite.
Ils nous font, ils nous y obligent même, réparer les choses
ou ils exigent quelque chose de mieux,
et je pense que l'on a besoin d'eux,
pour qu'ils fassent justement ça,
parce qu'après tout, ce n'est pas l'information
qui veut être libre, c'est nous.
Merci beaucoup.
Merci. (Applaudissements)
Hackez la planète !